[Música]
economía en directo américa france24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio daniel
hablando onda ni bienvenida a buena
mañana de martes y hay una primera
estimación en pakistán sobre cuánto
ascienden las pérdidas por estas
inundaciones monzónicas las más graves
en historia reciente de ese país más de
1.100 muertos 33 millones de personas
afectadas está grave la situación en
pakistán y señor pues estas inundaciones
sin precedentes porque son sin
precedentes y causadas como usted lo
dice por las lluvias históricas
monzónicas no solamente han matado todas
esas personas 1100 personas en las
últimas semanas y ha afectado al menos
al 15 por ciento de la población del
país también han arrasado con carreteras
con cultivos infraestructura y puentes
el ministro del cambio climático
calificó la situación como un desastre
de proporciones épicas y que ha
destruido casi un millón de casas
también calculó en 10 mil millones de
dólares las pérdidas generales de esta
catástrofe el gobierno calcula que
podrían tomarse unos cinco años
reconstruyendo las zonas afectadas y que
la consecuencia más y data será una
crisis alimentaria incluso raúl se
estaría considerando importar vegetales
en su archi virtual india a pesar de que
estos dos países no han tenido
relaciones comerciales por años
recordemos que ellos han tenido pues un
conflicto durante años naciones unidas
emitió un llamado urgente el martes para
conseguir entre sus miembros unos 160
millones de dólares para contribuir a
esta causa pero no dejan de hacer 160
millones para 10 mil millones que se
necesitan
danny australes le pone la lupa a las
grandes tecnológicas por los casos de
abuso infantil ya cambiamos de tema
bueno este país comenzó a aplicar línea
dura contra las llamadas big tex desde
2021 ahí dentro de las big ticket
podemos meter amazon facebook twitter a
todas las redes sociales y las grandes
tecnológicas y hasta ahora pues estas
medidas han incluido leyes que las
obligan a pagar a los medios de
comunicación por mostrar su contenido y
otras que les exigen entregar detalles
de cuentas anónimas que publican
material difamatorio en esta ocasión a
los script los directivos de facebook de
apple de microsoft y de snap chat entre
otras llegó una carta firmada por la
comisión de seguridad electrónica y les
dice tienen 28 días para que compartan
sus estrategias para acabar con el abuso
infantil en sus plataformas si no lo
hacen van a tener una multa de 383 mil
dólares por día de retraso will the king
charles action estamos viendo que la
explotación sexual infantil es el mayor
riesgo el mayor daño es contenido ilegal
con lo que estamos lidiando por lo que
esto que estamos haciendo tiene toda la
lógica y si las empresas no están
haciendo lo suficiente para abordar el
contenido ilegal y la violación la
tortura y el abuso de niños entonces que
más están permitiendo que sucedan sus
plataformas
bueno hablemos también de otra crisis
que tiene semanas digamos o quejándose
ahí en ese país porque el presidente de
la ncaa presentó un presupuesto con el
que busca detener la peor crisis
económica en décadas económica y social
la que bien nos integran que es ética y
pues entre los aspectos más destacados
de lo que plantea al parlamentó ranil
wickramasinghe quien también es conoce
el primero también es ministro de
finanzas del país figura en primer lugar
el programa de rescate que se está
negociando con el fondo monetario
internacional y que él dice que ya
alcanzó un nivel exitoso me imagino
proporcionará detalles más adelante
sobre lo que es este programa en general
la iniciativa recorta gastos y brinda
apoyos económicos a las familias de
escasos recursos y se financia con el
alza del iva del 12% al 15% y también
con la imposición de nuevos gravámenes
en 2023 todo eso para lograr un
crecimiento a mediano plazo del 5% anual
también plantea abrirse más a la
inversión extranjera pues este es un
país con enormes recursos naturales y
buscará negociar más tratados de libre
comercio todo eso suena muy bien raúl
ahora lo difícil será cumplir con este
presupuesto que debe aprobar el
parlamento teniendo en cuenta que este
es un país que está sin divisa en su
moneda está bastante devaluada desde
hace unos dos años y no tiene divisas
entonces le queda muy difícil también
aprobar presupuestos tan amigos
cambiamos nuevamente de tema danny
porque el turismo en francia- repuntó
este año de dos años de pandemia bueno
pues viajeros nacionales y extranjeros
ayudaron a reactivar a los sectores de
la hostelería y del ocio a niveles
anteriores a la crisis sanitaria en lo
que va del año les tengo esas cifras 35
millones de franceses se fueron de
vacaciones esto equivale al 70 por
ciento de la población y también sube un
60% frente al año pasado
recordemos que la actividad turística
representa al 8 por ciento del producto
interno bruto en francia y mantiene unos
2 millones de puestos de trabajo
la basílica del sagrado corazón una
iglesia en la colina de monmouth y que
ofrece vistas panorámicas de parís el
lugar es el favorito de los visitantes
turistas dicen que aprecian más el
tiempo en la capital francesa sobre todo
tras dos años de restricciones de ccoo y
teníamos planes para venir con la
familia a parís y también a otras partes
de europa occidental hace dos años pero
tuvimos que cancelar para el verano de
2020 entonces es un largo viaje aplazado
es agradable realmente se siente como el
verano como el coi se ha terminado al
menos en alemania son más estrictos con
las normas sanitarias
el sector turístico francés se recupera
el número de turistas ha vuelto a los
niveles anteriores a la pandemia casi 10
millones de extranjeros viajaron a la
ciudad luz este verano las ventas en
restaurantes y en el sector de la
hospitalidad alcanzaron récords
históricos
la ministra del turismo del país celebró
las últimas cifras
y
turistas europeos también americanos han
regresado a francia regresaron en
grandes cantidades y han gastado
sin embargo los chinos son los
principales ausentes las restricciones
estrictas de beijing les hacen imposible
viajar en 2017 el banco de francia
estimó que los chinos eran los primeros
clientes no europeos del país
representando más del 7 por ciento de
los ingresos del turismo otra
oportunidad perdida fue la falta de
personal la escasez de trabajadores hizo
que muchas empresas limitaron su
potencial a pesar de esto francia se
encamina a un año excepcional en
términos de ocupación hotelera
y ganas de volver a parís qué ganas de
volver a parís y comernos un macarrón
dios mío una copita de vino frente a la
torre eiffel pero bueno pronto
volveremos otra vez estamos aquí siempre
al digamos perdiste más de 18.000
empleos formales que generó brasil en
julio 28 5% menos que en igual periodo
del año pasado esto de dónde sale esta
cifra en julio se crean 1,9 millones de
puestos de trabajo y fueron despedidas
1,7 millones de personas en esta la
economía más grande de américa latina
tal y como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica y pasamos a
saludar a juan rubiales que nos tiene
todo el repaso por los deporte